pete thammel kind enough to join us on
loan from yahoo sports the national
college football reporter
and i'm not sure what's happening in
college football
i know there's a lot going on off the
field there pete i don't know how much
we're going to have on the field but
give me the cliff notes version of
what's going on with the pac-12 right
now
sure dan uh you know the pac-12
basically had a player-led
movement uh that manifested itself this
weekend with some online demands
and and they range from the very
pragmatic and realistic to consistent
health and safety protocols to six years
of insurance after a playing career ends
to the somewhat more unrealistic of half
of essentially the football revenue from
the pac-12
they also asked the commissioner and
coaches to take significant pay cuts to
help support them
so it was about when you really step
back from 30 000 feet and look at it
what you'd expect from a disparate group
of you know 18 to 22 year olds from 12
different schools
with certainly you know varying you know
coming from varying places
kind of trying to band together and make
some change there was some positive some
of the stuff gave you a little bit of
pause
but i think generally my takeaway is it
really created some positive dialogue
and the column i wrote for yahoo today
basically says look this is a window
into where we are
going forward in college sports you know
when we
mercifully put the pandemic behind us
and it's 2021 all of a sudden
you're gonna have name image and
likeness in college sports dan you're
gonna have free transfer and the voice
of the player through social media
and being less restricted by their
coaches as we've seen from the player
empowerment movement the past couple
months
is really going to change the whole
landscape of how college sports look and
operate
they had me up until we went 50 50
rebshare here
because the other part of this and i
agree we forget about college football
players
after they graduate if they graduate and
they don't go into the nfl
we use them and then we move on because
here comes the next
you know group of athletes here um
how many athletes are involved in this
and have we heard from any other
conferences yet
in a show of support so
it's a great question about the number
of athletes involved because they cast
it in their releases hundreds but when
you start calling coaches and ads and
around the league you know most places
are like
we've got three or four guys and there's
a there's a key line of demarcation and
that i think is going to define this
movement this
week dan there's the support for the
spirit and the tenor of the movement
which is support athletes rights and
privileges
and then there's the i'm going to sit
and opt out of games
in order to achieve this and we have
very little clarity right now
about where that line is drawn and in a
couple of uh young men in the pac-12
very very articulately said on uh
on twitter uh elijah molden at
washington being one of them look like i
support these things
but at the end of the day i need to go
play um and and that's i think where a
lot of this is going to come down to
so i'll be very curious to see i i think
the pac-12 is going to engage on this
to to you know to a to a healthy level
um but another
i think mistake they made is they
actually haven't approached the pac-12
or any of the
any of the schools yet they've simply
just put their demands out there in in
in media which um well you know how
negotiations for the media tend to go
over the years dan you probably talked
about that once or twice on your show
yes i have i start to look at the state
of college football and is
as optimistic as i want to be it's
really hard when you add realism
just being pragmatic about this i don't
know if the big ten is going to play
football this year
the sec it feels like you know we're the
sec we will play
the s the acc it feels like that the big
12 feels like that
i don't know about the pac-12 but the
fact that the big ten
they're holding internal conversations
about if they can pull this off
when are we gonna is there a date like
are these conferences schools gonna have
a drop dead date here pete
here's the bottom line dan they're
waiting for the decision to be made for
them
they're waiting for an mlb to fall apart
they're waiting for some seismic act
that's going to make this
obvious but right now the the plan is
i've joked in columns push push and hope
let's just push things back push things
back and hope things get better hope the
environment gets better
now you talk to some coaches they'll
tell you right now after having had
their
kids on campus for six to eight weeks
and having very few positive tests
they feel as good as ever like they love
some places they'd love to start camp
soon um and and that i would say is
probably the tenor in about half the
schools
the here the untenable variable dan that
i
that i really think everyone is sitting
back and bracing for and nobody has a
good answer to is what happens when
students come back
and that starts to happen as soon as the
next couple weeks because a lot of the
schools in the
in the northeast big ten footprint are
starting in early august so they can
leave
by uh by thanksgiving to to reduce
travel
when you bring ten thousand twenty
thousand thirty thousand students to
campus the virus is going to come with
them
and i and i really think that is going
to be the fact that
exposes an unbubbled option like we're
seeing in major league baseball
he's pete thamel covers college football
for yahoo sports i was wondering about
college football campuses uh i remember
being on the basketball team we had a
basketball dorm
can you create a bubble for these
football players
where they have their own dorm and maybe
they're not going to classes you know
physically going to classes but you do
it
remotely but you're you're there they
know why they're there i know that
they're going to they want to get an
education but
let's not kid anybody if you want to
quarantine them put them in a bubble
uh and have restrictions like you do
with nba players
uh is that possible for some of these
big time schools
i think it's possible i also think
that's fraught with some some ethical
and optical issues um the irony is camp
which is you know has started at places
like oklahoma and kansas on
on friday tends to be a bubble situation
guys go to the same dorm guys go to a
hotel
like there is that and with with really
few other students around
it's very feasible but for a for a
school to come out and say
we're essentially locking our guys in a
dorm or locking our guys in a in a hotel
so they can play football i just don't i
just really don't think optically that's
going to fly
what is the oddest option you've heard
so far
i mean there's there you do hear a
little bit of everything some people
saying
well we try to play three or four games
in the fall and then maybe try to play
you know
the rest of it in the spring like that
that's been a season
yes a split season i would say that is
the that is the strangest
yeah and i if i'm a player playing in
the big 12 or you know these
power five conferences i don't want to
play in the spring
because you can't have two college
football seasons in a nine-month span
i just don't see that working i do think
that these smaller schools smaller
conferences will opt for the spring
because that's wide open for tv you know
for eyeballs
on your sport on your school and a lot
of those players aren't going to be
going to the combine or getting drafted
so i see that
i also brought this up a source
yesterday said
you're going to get your wish the power
5 is going to eventually secede from the
ncaa
and i said it's not my wish just my
prediction he said it's not a question
of if but when
that the power 5 really has no need for
the ncaa
when do you do you think do you agree
with that
i think that has long been kind of a
final four bar
conversation but there's there's billion
dollar television contracts that have
said look college sports are really
bound by television contracts right
college football playoff
is a television contract it's not like
an entity it's one guy runs it
and it's a multi-billion dollar tv deal
the conferences are linked by that
the ncaa exists because of the
multi-billion dollar
tv deal it here's the thing if if all
these schools broke away
they're not always going to suddenly
start paying the you know the left guard
at toledo 30 grand
like it's still going to be some other
form of amateur athletics uh
the ncaa has been underwhelming mark
emerick has clearly been underwhelming
in all this he's been basically
invisible
and i do feel like that is coming to a
head when people do say there is a
breakaway my question to them is
what does that breakaway actually look
like like say you didn't like the
accounting department at your fortune
500 company
if you got rid of them you'd still need
an accounting department and that's
essentially what the ncaa is
95 of it is championship running back
room work
you know be it enforcement compliance
type stuff etc
and a majority of that is is is fairly
functional more functional than we
probably give the nsa credit for
it's the high-end leadership and the
difficulty of managing a system that has
maine and miami under the same set of
rules
where they've really struggled and
obviously not adapt
pete good to talk to you i have no idea
if i talk to you in a month from now
what's the headline i want to give you
the other odd option i've been joking
with the coach about the new zealand
nova scotia option where there's no
virus that they could move like
all the conferences to either new
zealand and nova scotia wait wait you
didn't use that as the craziest option
it took me a second it took me a second
it came to me though i
yes so hopefully uh hopefully i'll see
you in auckland uh
from the uh from the show here well i
i've been to nova scotia it's a
beautiful beautiful place but uh yeah i
don't know if they have the facilities
there in nova scotia
just make it work like orchard said just
we'd line up in a pasture at midnight
we'd line up in the past year midnight
uh pete thank you buddy we appreciate
your time
thank you dan that's pete family covers
uh college football for yahoo sports